la première fois que camille cottin a
crevé l'écran
c'était en 2008 devant la caméra de wes
anderson dans un film avec brad pitt si
si c'est vrai regardez elle et l'a fait
un petit rôle certes pour une pub
japonaise certes mais qui a scellé le
destin de la jeune fille et en 2013
après quelques années au théâtre dans la
troupe de pierre palmade ce sera
peut-être même pas un gars au non moins
fils par aussi camille caudin croiser la
route de deux réalisatrices qui en un
casting en totale impro vont changer sa
vie
on avait imaginé donc ce programme court
kaunas c'est camille chamoux qu'on vous
la voir et qui nous a dit mais voyez
camille peau tant qu'il est un tout
petit peu la relative les messieurs
parce que l'on fait le casting chez une
des productrices avec un appareil
photo/vidéo donc est grand comme ça elle
était sur le canapé je moi je jouais le
taxi est donc jeu on lui a fait faire
une petite impro s'éteigne pas moi
j'adore son petit corps très énergique
et on aime bien aussi le côté physique
très filles petites choses et la grosse
voix et puma elle déchire elle déchire
son casting quoi kaunas avec ses
punchlines devient tout de suite culte
ce qui s'annonce dorée soixante douze
épisodes après les trois copines adapte
le double maléfique de camille en film
je sais que camille a énormément stressé
à la sortie du film
lc 10 et moins qui porte ce truc seul
sur mes épaules et c'était vrai le
résultat un million deux cent mille
spectateurs et une nomination au césar
de meilleur espoir
camille caudin contre toute attente
vient de braquer le métier tous les
directeurs de casting se sont mis à
penser avec un ami cottin appelé camille
caudin elle est belle arrivée dans le
radar désormais ultra demandé
camille enchaîne quelques comédies aux
côtés de pio marmaï ou encore manu payet
avant de prendre un virage à 180 degrés
dans la seine 10 % allez tu vas faire
cette scène de cul un champion tu nous
donnes toute puissante frites dedans
elle incarne andrea martèle un agent
lesbiennes qui gère la carrière et les
crises d'ego de célébrités jouant leur
propre rôle chez nous pour vous ah bon
pour moi vous êtes un acteur rares
fabrice j'en ai assez d'attendre une
occasion qui se présente jamais je
provoque le destin mais vous proposez
quoi alors
un nouveau souffle c'était évident que
c'était elle parce qu'elle correspondait
on sait très bien que ça super et d'une
personne vivante qui est la bête à néant
mais en même temps qui n'est pas un
personnage public
donc ya pas la pression de rendre un
résultat attendu conforme à ce que les
gens père sujet sept personnes et en
même temps c'est comme une source
d'inspiration mais c'est un beau très
très très beau personnage andra c'est un
personnage inspirante défendent prise de
position queyrac est importante un rôle
salué par la critique qui en plus
d'installer l'actrice fait écho
conviction qu'il anime comme la lutte
contre l'homophobie
je crois que c'est la première lesbienne
du paf à 20h30 en chaîne hertzienne
peut-être qu andré a influencé la jeune
génération a milité pour la pma et ça
c'est bien mais ce qui caractérise
surtout camille caudin c'est son
addiction au travail je pense que j'ai
trouvé dans le travail une liberté
quelque chose qui fait que quand je
travaille je suis libéré de mes de
certaines angoisses ou de voilà il ya
quelque chose qui m'épanouit
profondément d'être dans la matière
comment plus de 10%
c'est pas moins de quatre projets par an
4 à chaque fois assez drôle je savais
pas que l'actrice mène de front sur
grand écran
parmi eux iris avec romain duris telle
mère telle fille avec juliette binoche
en 2017 et largué avec miou-miou et
camille chamoux en 2018
alors c'est sympa c'est très sympa
et s'appelle thierry je renvoie ce soir
il m'invite à sortir ça un trio de
femmes qui a réuni 800 mille spectateurs
et lui a valu le prix d'interprétation
au festival de la comédie de l'alpe
d'huez
camille cottin
[Applaudissements]
je pense que ce prix c'est le prix de
toute l'équipe de l'art y est donc bravo
et merci pour ce film
et oui quel que soit le registre pour
camille jouer est une nécessité
y a pas de stratégie pas très
stratégique ce qui me disait fabrice m'a
fait rire faisait souvent les
comédiennes on a envie de leur dire
arrête de calcul est fait les choses
juste pour le plaisir de l'effet habille
toi c'est le contraire il faudrait que
tu met un peu d'ordre
fabrice c'est fabrice luchini que
camille caudin retrouve aujourd'hui dans
le mystère henry pic de rémi bezançon
que pose la question tout haut que
beaucoup de gens se pensent tout bas
etes-vous certaine que c'est bien votre
mari qui est écrit ce roman qui est en
train de manquer de mon mari violent et
vous l'imaginez le pizzaïolo breton qui
pointent à bouquin de cette envergure
est sérieusement tu vois pas pas écrire
ça entre deux fonds de peter j'ignore
qui a écrit ce livre et je vais trouver
un temps d'amis père complices qui
illumine cette enquête littéraire
mystérieuse et légère d'un côté un petit
peu way un petit peu cher et chats on
est là ils sont toujours en train se
contredit ce qui fait c'est ce qui fait
qu'ils se plaisent kouame khamis avait
quelqu'un de caractère aussi donc à lui
tient facilement en tête et pourtant
elle était très impressionné parce que
fabrice luchini ce n'est pas n'importe
qui quand même rien n'est dit que les
dernières heures d'une histoire d'amour
et la jeune fille de sibérie ne sont
qu'un seul et même roman n'avait aucune
preuve
et vous oubliez la machine à écrire la
fin de mon père vous allez arrêter de me
contrarier gens quelles raisons de le
priver d'un tel plaisir
le jeu me passionne est tombé sur un
aide comme sac est une machine à jouer
comme d'isabelle huppert une machine à
jouer si si rapide qu'un sens du rythme
y a pas d' acteurs actrices ou acteur
efficace dans la comédie s'ils n'ont pas
un sens aigu du rythme là ça passe pas
par la tête
voilà qu'elle soit kaunas flic bottes à
geaune star détective camille aborde
chaque rôle avec la même sincérité et il
va falloir vous y habituer